biden's buildback better agenda is in
full meltdown mode and it shows joe
practically pleading with democrats to
save him
we need to stay together
and bound by the values that we hold as
a party
because here's the deal we want 2020 as
a unified party
and we look to 2022 as we do that we
need to stay unified meanwhile democrats
are worrying that biden's tanking poll
numbers will sink their chances at
holding on to congress in 2022 dana so
it's game of chicken between the
moderates and the far left biden has
thrown in with the far left someone's
gonna have to cave or compromise by the
end of the year well i think that they
look at all of their numbers and and
they realize there's a cascade of a lack
of confidence
and all of the issues you could take
down them from education immigration uh
inflation uh foreign policy afghanistan
like all of that so
that means that joe biden's credit in
terms of political capital is really low
so he doesn't have anything any like
juice right to call and say you better
get in line because he said he was going
to run as the moderate he was going to
run as a person that would unite
everybody and he's not done that for the
first nine months now now basically
everything's up everybody everybody gets
it
he won the battle but bernie sanders won
the war and now they're calling all the
shots there's a woman named abigail
spamberger she's a congresswoman from
virginia and she wrote an op-ed in the
washington post yesterday basically
saying we really need this
infrastructure bill but that ship has
sailed
president biden said no they will be
linked with the 3.5 trillion or whatever
they end up with now i will say this um
do not underestimate their ability to
get something done they'll get something
done i think that they'll they they know
they have to have something to run on
and so someone eventually will cave but
i do think it will be the moderates you
do well the moderates the only reason
they have the house majority so that
would be on the house side i don't know
about mansion and cinema okay on the
house all right greg your thoughts i'm
just thinking about a spam burger
delicious i mean that's very big in
hawaii
fry up some spam put it on a potato bun
well her name is span burger if i
pronounced it incorrectly i apologize
but a spam burger is also something i
prefer to think of it as a spam burger
it's amazing to see the grand unifier
who thought he could unify a country
cannot unify his party he can barely
unify his bathrobe so why is this the
case his only purpose as you said was to
unify a voting mass to beat trump and it
wasn't really that hard for him because
they just needed the vessel they needed
the look of an old white moderate that's
as comfy as milk and cookies at bedtime
and now what's happening is you're
watching the whole thing implode it was
a trick we're all seeing and the voting
public is seeing what's behind the
curtain that he was just a false front
you know designed to win an election and
now the implosion comes now and later
the thing is though if you were given
the cho the choice this is what you
would have done do you want to be bernie
sanders and lose or do you want to
pretend to be something else and win
so they still they still won they pulled
it they pulled the wool if i may say so
over our eyes or the bathrobe the
bathroom dig it in the poll came out
over cbs no one even knows what is in
this thing and no one thinks it's
actually going to help the economy or
their own family so that whatever
they're pushing
infrastructure build back better no one
even knows what's in it the american
people are smart despite the way that
biden companies speak to the vast
majority of this country and they know
inflation is spiking you have a variety
of commodities that are near or at
all-time highs gasoline prices at a
seven-year high and they look at five
trillion dollars in this new century
welfare monstrosity
and they think more money equals more
inflation despite what gensake says that
we need to spend money to solve the
inflation problem so it is simple it is
that simple that they don't they're not
behind this
the american people for that very reason
however joe biden is standing up there
like willie lowman trying to sell it to
america and
in terms of unity i think 48 out of 50
democratic senators in favor of this new
century welfare monstrosity that's
pretty good that's 96
yeah of the democrats in the senate so
what happened to the party that they're
only two people are saying oh you know
social security and medicare 112
trillion dollar hole over 30 years in
medicare's hospital funds running out of
money in five years
there's nobody there standing up for
well not banked up in america so
herefore junior what is going on is joe
biden working the phones and no one's
listening or is he not working the
phones what's happening here
he should be working the phones and the
only thing he should be saying is that
the country's prepared to pass an
infrastructure plan let's do it the rest
of this stuff let's come back let's see
how the country digests the first set of
things but he already said he already
said no to that when he went to the hill
well he can change his mind i mean every
politician deserves the right to change
his or her mind and he if he's going to
find his way to higher ground he's got
to do this look he was you're right greg
he was elected on kovic and i think his
numbers are falling largely because
people are saying my lives are not
normal every time even the first story
the the southwest pilots are saying
what's wrong why can't we get some
normalcy here people come at it from
different ways dang and i may disagree
on this but we all want this matter to
be resolved and we're not there people
thought his
his his his stability and competence
would would find its way through and and
frankly it has not and then you have a
party unfortunately my old piles in the
congress they seem to think that they
have a 50-seat majority in the house and
a 15-seat majority in the senate you
don't
if you get there if you get there then
you can come back and perhaps do some of
these things the country would have said
this is what we want the country is
willing to go forward on some things and
the thing that they're willing to go
forward on is what joe biden and
republicans and democrats in the senate
including joe manchin and kristen
cinnamon negotiate it pass that first
wow you're making a lot of sense here
before junior i don't know what to make
of that
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else